what's up guys I'm Ryan right today I am
periscoping with some fans they wanted
to see a live reaction of this so I was
like they just want to see me stare to
[ __ ] screen for a while with them not
knowing what I'm staring at so let's go
do this American Horror Story hotel the
hallways TV spot I love American Horror
Story brilliant why is the battery
already blinking I charged you for like
an hour and a half you [ __ ]
kermy kermy kermy
taking the music right now
lady gaga
okay good trailer so far because it's
really capturing the tone and style and
the different I love about each season
there's a different type of visual
aesthetic there's a different type of
visual imagery and it does have that
like classic haunted hotel vibe about it
but you know like even more because it's
American Horror Story they know how to
take plastic feeling vibes but amplify
it and make it a little modern-day that
modern day kind of extra touch on it but
yeah this is like 30 seconds it's cool
to see a lot of the cast returning Kathy
Bates especially hotel above and below
at the gaga
okay from watching both of these
trailers I'm getting a vibe that it's
like how do I put it I'm getting a vibe
that it's gonna be a lot more ecstatic
it's gonna be a lot like freakier like
this this feels like I mean I know this
freak show but this feels like it's
gonna be like mayhem with energy and
stuff and crazy visuals and that's what
is really appealing to me about this
because it looks like they're going all
out with striking visual imagery really
allowing that to feel like it kind of
feels like out here in California in
Long Beach they have the Queen Mary
which is a haunted ship you could
actually get a hotel there and stuff
it's but it's supposedly haunted they do
a bunch of mazes kind of has a rave vibe
I get like a similar vibe from this you
kind of got like that underground rave
dark vibe and like feels like it's mazes
and [ __ ] I mean it's a hotel hotels are
scary because I mean someone has access
to your [ __ ] door no like they can
just come in at any time like the
cleaning people and and the manager and
stuff like they could just come in at
any time you don't know who's in a hotel
it's such a variety of people like it's
it's a great setup for horror because
hotels can be terrifying
yeah I'm just loving the way all the
production value looks and it looks
really artistic at the same time like it
it's one of those horror themes where
it's like it's more than just like
disturbing and haunting it's also kind
of beautiful to look at and I'm just
excited to bringing back a lot of the
you know I love how they keep using a
lot of the cast on previous seasons a
lot of the actors and they bring them
back for newer seasons so I really
appreciate that and yeah I'm definitely
gonna tune in for it and I just wish
American Horror Story had some sex like
a lot more sex I could go for more sex
in American Horror Story sex is good you
tell screen junkies you want me on there
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to it you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine and periscope because if we get
enough followers especially on periscope
I can get more product placement product
placements great it allows me to do the
same amount of work but may double the
money so why wouldn't you want to help
me do that yes selfish [ __ ] oh yeah I
keep forgetting to say subscribe today
and become a real reject or should I
just say reject I say subscribe today
and become a reject or subscribe today
and become a real reject which one
sounds better real reject just two
rejects real reject become a read okay
you guys are confusing me it's a real
split decision here yeah camera or just
reject so subscribe today and become a
reject today subscribe and become a
reject subscribe today and get rejected
not hashtag something with the word
reject